I don’t know about you, but thunderstorms
scare the hell out of me.
Lightning may never strike in the same place
twice, but based on the following video, I
think we’re going to run out of places to
hide real real soon.
Hey folks, I’m Matt Lieberman filling in
for DNews.
According to Climate scientists from the University
of California, Berkeley, global warming will
cause the amount of air to ground lightning
strikes to increase by 50% by the end of this
century.
Now, that may feel far away right now, but
the road to lightning palooza, as it will
now be called, is not going to be fun for
anyone.
So, how are global warming and lightning connected?
Well, lightning strikes are caused by charge
separation in clouds, which are composed of
water and ice molecules.
Atmospheric water molecules are essentially
lightning fuel.
Now, increased global temperatures will cause
more water to evaporate into the atmosphere.
Imagine a bomb dropped into a barrel of gunpowder
in one of those oldschool rooms packed to
the gills with TNT.
In a house that’s on fire.
The opportunity for explosive deep convection
skyrockets under these conditions, sharply
raising the risk of human injury and wildfires.
Jeez.
Hold on, excuse me, science?
How did we get to this conclusion, science?
I’ll tell you, me!
You see, convection, the thermal transfer
of energy through fluid and gas, has long
been measured by precipitation, namely, the
amount of rain, snow, and hail that hits the
ground during a given period.
However, that doesn’t account for the ascent
speeds of moisture into the atmosphere.
This is a factor known as CAPE, or Convective
Available Potential Energy, which is measured
via instruments released twice daily into
the atmosphere via weather balloons.
Essentially, CAPE measures how fast and far
a moist pocket of air could travel into the
upper atmosphere, releasing explosive charges.
Armed with this information, scientists can
actually now predict 77 percent of lightning
strikes.
Scientists then applied their new CAPE data
to 11 climate models that predict precipitation
throughout the century and reached their conclusion.
As it turns out, CAPE in the U.S. will rise
by 11 percent for every degree celsius that
our global temperature rises.
Combined with small increases in precipitation
levels and based on the projected four degree
increase worldwide by 2100, lightning strikes
will rise by 50%.
Just another reason to try to curb global
warming before it zaps us back.
So how do you feel about lightning?
Are you concerned about the potential increase?
Let us know in the comments below.
I’m Matt Lieberman filling in for DNews.
You can find more of my videos over at Sourcefed.
Please like the video and subscribe to the
channel.
Thanks for watching.